this looks pretty good
mushroom L thinking hey burger positive
ranked this wrong
I want the Baconator what a [ __ ] that
yo sup guys my name is Q and today we're
gonna be trying some Wendy's from the us
some Tokyo see how they can [ __ ] each
other I'm excited I love one it should
be fun alright so let's start off what
do we got here I mean well for starters
with the this is the smallest frosty
I've ever seen in my life
cute though really cute this is classic
I mean if you go to Wendy's you have to
have a frosty mmm this is great just
heartburn Britain this is one of the
best thing to to the horde at Wendy's
protip though you gotta dip the fries in
there you guys do that right right in
the frosty mmm fries in the frozen it's
a thing mm-hmm I'm telling if you've
never done this before
different level of tastiness this is the
one hi guys I'm officially in Tokyo at
the nine hours capsule hotel you should
yuku inside my capsule I have like
people on there right not left to be
obviously so I'm trying to keep it okay
yeah so let's get into this Wendy's they
ask so much stuff here stuff I did
nothing they would have here is all
Wendy's first kitchen I'm not sure walk
maybe it was here first I don't know I'm
excited to show you guys her up it's
pretty dope this is not like honey what
Robbie mochi with ice cream I never had
much in before I don't think yes I'm a
mochi very chewy almost gelatinous but
like chewy I flood I just says stupid
sorry I'm not Adam in Andrew oh yes
Stephen I don't know what the [ __ ] was
it was its closing her mouth
very
vividly my technical very frosty
probably different it's definitely it
would easily be the second best dessert
any you guys like so this is like type
of bulb of tea and got a little balls at
the bottom - I'm super Alan be right
here this is beau bonus my friend yeah
this is this is so good how many say
this is this is the best thing it's fine
swag not for this fire surprising
Wendy's I think McDonald's has the best
fries as far as fast food but Wendy's is
like a close third I was a second type
like Burger King my obsession the windy
sparse oh great they're always super
salty like I thought that's not like
their orientation when you saw the fries
over talked about three times and it's
good to me when these fires amazing
versus Tokyo Tokyo doesn't suck their
fries a lot and I notice from experience
Wendy's fries Wendy's Frosty's right now
we're two for two you really can't beat
them they all hand in here I flew it on
the teens are probably better yeah I'm
definitely taking the u.s. fries over
guys it's like fries with like popcorn
cheese you know like a little cheese
about it put on it this is one flavor
they're like four different seven
different drugs maybe the other fries
are pretty good these are like super
okay this looks pretty good this is the
baked potato with cheese and bacon this
is also some American bullet for sure oh
we would do that that's not good for
nobody
that looks delicious this looks fired I
feel like they should put some sour
cream in here
you know that's really good this is the
best thing I've tried so far I feel like
if I ate one of these I wouldn't even
need a burger see this is what the u.s.
is good for and they'll make something
that's just so bad for you but it's just
so good at the same time that's why you
know that's why I enjoy living here eat
good die pass
I'm not really offended like nacho
cheese but this cheese seems like it's
like real cheese nothing I've ever
ordered this before but this is like
good this would be a new pickup for me
if I go back to Wendy's like I'll cop
this just in the fire section right here
[Music]
it's what you would expect some fast
food pretty good this is the first fast
food I think any chapstick maybe this is
the most American thing you can eat
as a wine this is a spicy chicken
sandwich this bun looks great this
interesting when I go to Windies I'd
never order chicken sandwiches like when
I think the Wendy's I only think about
burgers and I think this is show me why
it is spicy though I feel like some
spicy chicken sandwiches aren't nicely
spicy this one's actually spicy it's
just a chicken in like crunchy like the
popeyes chicken sandwich is crunchy I
feel like the one in Tokyo is gonna be
super crunchy super good this one is
okay this is some chicken sandwich your
swords that's about to make a huge mess
and my in my pod
[Music]
i smear positive write this one off up
the back it just look like it did it
like it just doesn't look like anything
special but this is fine all right this
is the chili at chili from Wendy's they
gave me some onions on the side yeah
this has to be for this toss those in
there mmm yo this is also really good
yes is mine ok Wendy's is really coming
through with them with the heat right
now
it's like I know on a cold day like a
rainy day I'll eat this with the cheese
and the onions on the side I'm pretty
impressed
ok anyone that's going back in the fire
section that's everything
I was not expecting for them to have
chicken curry bread like the Paradise
sweet super spicy
I wouldn't even say I fled discount
replace my chili no I mean even though
they do have chili they actually put
this is like it says step over and the
Broncos actually good these little mini
pancakes they taste like buttery
pancakes
I guess my butter on these for short the
batter I see the butter on that's like
super buttery that's crazy
that's great you know I love sweets I
love cake this is good so sir it's a
wrap
he's fire that option to get him some
ice cream too so this is the junior
bacon cheeseburger deluxe so me and my
mom used to order these all the time
this is like everything to order this
might not be the best sandwich ever but
she would also put honey on the burger
it was great it was amazing shout out to
my mom this is like a nice sized burger
that's not going to okay sections into a
wild rock burger took this out and beef
patties
[Music]
you begin lettuce tomatoes eggs okay I
wasn't expecting mr. our Tokyo Whitney's
other being the other news out never
this but they taking it up here I'm not
to take the most serious net back but
this is the Cody Jack mushroom melt
bacon egg burger I like to say I'd like
to eat looks pretty good though this is
on my heli this is good nothing is great
but it's good wild rock one way better
it's the bun it amazing the sandwiches
slightly confusing super regular and now
I'm measuring in comparison to the
Baconator this is much more doable like
this is what I do as a young boy this is
what I do as a grown disgusting man look
I eat like two of these a week I had one
last night I feel like just say what
your loan is gonna make the USA win you
don't get more gluttonously American
than this
alright let's have a list of tonight
which I know will mm-hmm people we got
two layers of meat two layers of bacon
two layers of cheese this is good this
right here and definitely the bacon
[Music]
bacon here whoa that's crispy us big I
doubt it
bless you
see from looks this is way better than
the US Wendy's Baconator then super
thick the bacon is super thick and
crispy that's pretty impressive
this is mommy these patties are way
bigger - bacon is way bigger it makes it
too much and I think and I'm my ex
credit the bacon like a big piece of the
Beckman is the amount of mayonnaise and
ketchup they put on it this lacks that
what makes it all burger all bacon all
cheese which is equal to a heart attack
sometimes too much it's too much
all right so overall Wendy's as a whole
across the board US and Tokyo has been
super impressive
I mean it's bar far one of my favorite
fast-food places the Baconator is always
gonna win it for me and I'm pretty happy
like I'm not mad with this at all so I'd
say so far with fast food in general I'm
gonna say Wendy's got it
these two right here that's it I'm done
I'm beyond impressed with a Tokyo with
these this one has done kind of get me
to Tokyo
five out of seven things I have was like
fire other stuff we just like okay I'm
not sure if this because this movie I
will say you don't think still go
[Music]
you
[Music]